hey what's going on
whoa what's going on it's no burr it's
the Monday morning podcast so Monday
February 6 2017 I'm doing it right after
the Super Bowl just because I got the
little one now and she's going to keep
me up all night so I knew there was no
way is everybody text me right now
speechless
something you never hear for me I'm
always running my mouth I am absolutely
speechless speechless I cannot believe
we came back and won that game I'm not
going to be that guy going dude I knew
it I was like is he feeling right I said
this I didn't I had my [ __ ] head in
the oven at halftime we were so getting
our ass kicked at like 21 to nothing
when Brady threw a pick six I have this
theory at the NFL level that if you
throw a pick six you don't win the game
they're too [ __ ] good it's the most
devastating [ __ ] play literally you
know if I saw one time a NFL Films one
of the players said that you're trying
to score not only the other team stopped
you they turn around and score on that
[ __ ] play it's like I can't believe
it 21 3 then was 28 to 3
I wasn't even like actually texted a
semi going like this is the longest
[ __ ] loss I've ever watched in my
life I'm like this is just slowly going
to what is this going to end up being
like 35 10 are they going to bring their
[ __ ] bench in I had completely
mentally thrown in the towel and I was
just sitting here you know and I
couldn't scream and yell you know I got
my girl now and just hilarious I'm just
it may go well as she's keeping me calm
but they was so kicking our ass I
couldn't even get upset and if you
watched when I was promoting my special
and when people would ask me about the
game I was I was not comfortable at all
and you know I went from like not even
believing in Atlanta against Seattle
pickin against them again when they
played Green Bay
and I was just after I saw the way they
played
I was like man they got they got a great
running back
they got Julio Jones Matt Ryan seems
dialed and all that [ __ ] that I said and
then right before the Superbowl they're
like dude they don't have one running
back they got to they got that Coleman
guy too so I was like like this and I
don't know I just had that [ __ ] you
know that feeling you have when you give
you think your team's going to lose but
you don't want to say it that's why I
was saying everybody on those shows
going like you know I'd bet the under
which didn't come in and I said I would
like the Falcons getting if I could get
five I think that I wasn't comfortable
taking the Patriots given points so I
can't say I called it on any [ __ ]
level I didn't I am absolutely [ __ ]
speechless I can't believe it I just
cannot believe it and I've never said
this before but I think I can finally
say it I think Tom Brady's the greatest
of all time I always gave the nod to
Montana because he went to four it took
him four trips to win four but even then
it's always up for debate because what
if Montana had Belichick what you have
is the greatest head coach in arguably
arguably the greatest if not now five
rings it's a great argument the greatest
[ __ ] quarterback of all [ __ ] time
you know playing together I can't I
cannot [ __ ] believe it
I can't and I didn't have any emotion
the whole game I just because we just so
[ __ ] losing so just sitting there and
then as we move slowly I wasn't I wasn't
even calling and saying that we were
coming back I was loud maybe they'll
make it a little respectable I don't
know all right you know maybe we just
lose by 10 and then you know we scored
that first two-point conversion even
then when we were going down the field
I'm like what are the odds we're going
to get another [ __ ] two-point
reversion we [ __ ] missed a field goal
we [ __ ] screwed up and I beat the
onside kick and to the greatest Super
Bowl catches I've seen since the helmet
catch was Julio Jones Jesus Christ and
what a [ __ ] throw Matt Ryan was also
running when he made that throw I was
like oh my god every [ __ ] Super Bowl
now every Super Bowl
is that [ __ ] ghost of evil it isn't
Eli it's like the ghost of Eli [ __ ]
throw and for once we had a Edelman we
had a circus catch back and I don't know
I I'm absolutely stunned and haven't
said all that my condolences to the Lana
Falcons fans I got no beef with you guys
and I've been there plenty of [ __ ]
times certainly for the first you know
36 years of my life if there was a
[ __ ] way to choke away a goddamn game
I saw a Boston team do it and for
whatever [ __ ] reason I don't know why
this is happening I don't know why it's
happened this [ __ ] long just trying
to enjoy it this is how spoiled Boston
fans are my daughter's two weeks old and
she's already seen her first Boston
title [ __ ] unbelievable and I got a
big kick out of Bill Maher trash in the
Patriots of course I thought he just
trashing is he talking sports
that's like me talking politics this
guy's getting outside of his Lane but
then I saw he was mad I guess he was mad
because uh you know Brady and I guess
somebody else I don't pay attention alas
[ __ ] so proper [ __ ] I guess they're
like Trump supporters and I heard on the
radio that you know I don't know Brady
did or didn't go when Obama was there I
don't [ __ ] know so this the Patriots
aren't at the height of their hatred if
he shows up now if he didn't go to the
Obama thing and then shows up at the
Trump thing that's going to be a
complete [ __ ] show but they seem to
drive being hated so what a [ __ ]
season starts off with that [ __ ]
horseshit the biggest like witch hunt
I've ever seen in my life that stupid
[ __ ] deflategate thing and just all
the justice that came out of it the fact
that it went to court it got laughed out
of court to the point the judge was
actually pissed then they finally get
the [ __ ] thing they just I don't know
they just but well those were
corporation we were right to suspend our
employee yes you do he's our employee
you're [ __ ] suspended so then he sits
there for [ __ ] games and I just
started thinking well five days then we
have a rested pissed off Tom Brady
without those [ __ ] miles maybe that
will be a good
thing it just how poetic was the whole
thing you know that line back from
Indianapolis who I don't have any
[ __ ] beef with because he said he
didn't want to be in the middle but the
linebacker who caught the ball that he
brought to the sideline as a souvenir
that touched off the whole deflategate
thing he tested positive for steroids
and got a four-game suspension it's
funny how ESPN really didn't do you know
you think they'd still be talking about
that yep never happened you know and
also fellas funny bill mark oldest
cheaters as we're playing the Atlanta
Falcons who got busted pumping [ __ ]
crowd noise in but that's okay it's okay
who gives a [ __ ] you know an NBA when
they go you know on basketball they go
the ball don't lie that's what I feel
like just [ __ ] happens after all of
that [ __ ]
vindication he comes back and he wins it
and then Roger Goodell like like the end
of a [ __ ] die hard movie the police
commissioner who didn't [ __ ] believe
in the rogue cop has to come in and
finally get in and be like you know what
you're a good cup here's your gun and
your badge back right brady sitting
there with his [ __ ] dirty [ __ ]
wife beater on jesus christ and i will
never [ __ ] ever talent you don't
Keith Robinson called it I'm going to
find the [ __ ] text message I'm going
to read you some of these function text
right now because I hate when [ __ ]
people [ __ ] quit you know and then
they don't admit to it I did I was like
this this game is [ __ ] over they're
younger they're faster and then we'd get
a break in the game then they'd get a
[ __ ] big sack I mean they're really
really good team
hang on let me find this [ __ ] thing I
had a buddy of mine he text me at
halftime he said I took Atlanta in the
under and I was like great bet I didn't
hear from till after the overtime and
then he text me he just texted fixed all
right oh my god I felt so bad for
[ __ ] Atlanta's owner he seems like
such a great guy you know you know it
looks like [ __ ] grandpa monster and
he made the [ __ ] Jerry Jones the
Jerry Jones move you come down on the
field before you put the game away many
understand it did you see when he had
that glum look on his face and is I
don't know what you know you never know
what those super rich guys it's like
that your daughter or your [ __ ] third
wife whoever the [ __ ]
was with them just sort of glanced at
him like oh god he's going to be hitting
a bottle tonight that poor bastard all
right wait where is it uh what did I say
here
okay first text I sent at 4:55 p.m.
Pacific Coast time have I ever told you
might pick six rule if you throw a pick
six during an NFL game you lose not to
mention we are down 21 nothing I bet the
under it's 59 the paid if the Patriots
don't start playing defense the Falcons
will score 60 lol he writes aha the
Falcons give up a lead all the time he
said that at 21 nothing this is chief
Robinson who I'll now say the great
Keith Robinson Tom Brady the greatest of
all time Keith Robinson he's the great
Keith Robinson right then I wrote we
look like [ __ ] against the Texans and
the Steelers weren't that tough ok 619
p.m. this loss is taking forever
I had no believe you know Glenn close to
the natural when she stands up and he
looks into the stands if let's say me
and Robert Redford had an alternative
lifestyle relationship when he looked up
in the stance I would have been gone he
would have seen the back of my head
walking out of the [ __ ] stadium he
goes they can still come back and I just
I just left I laughed at him and I just
said they are younger and faster AFC was
weak and then there's no more texture
while they rights back told you and then
I wrote right you might be right
then I wrote that's one of the best
catches I've ever seen that was the
Julio Jones and then I wrote this
grandpa Munster owned the Falcon since
when he was down on the thing and then
after that he was just calling me up and
he just kept saying this is what Atlanta
does and I was like you're right you're
absolutely right I don't know but you
know I sat and watched the whole [ __ ]
thing thank God I didn't turn on some
Mary Tyler Moore tribute by the way god
rest her soul one of my favorites of all
time I cannot [ __ ] believe it
I cannot [ __ ] him I just sat here
I ain't just accepting defeat going like
a well you know we'll see what the [ __ ]
I can't I can't [ __ ] believe it I
can't believe it
so there you go five [ __ ] rings Tom
Brady the greatest of all time and once
again I always have to say this because
I'd [ __ ] it I went to that Green Bay
Packers Patriots Super Bowl you know
Jesus Christ I watched the [ __ ] when
the first year I watch the Red Sox was
1978 Bucky Dent I still remember my
mother's face in the kitchen came in I
was like mom is there another game
tomorrow she just looked over at me and
didn't say anything she just shook her
head shook it no oh [ __ ]
anyways alright enough of that I don't
even know what else to [ __ ] talk
about I got uh oh you know what I did
the ice house this weekend it was the
first time it was great to see the
bushes by the way because I know that
they were in the [ __ ] in the hospital
whatever regardless of your politics
guys a war hero you don't see somebody
[ __ ] I mean I guess you die at some
point right you know took a lot of balls
from to go out there you know I want to
dumb it you don't I mean I get to mic
those [ __ ] years you [ __ ] wheeling
me around and [ __ ] it bill you want to
throw that coin you know you want to
[ __ ] flip the coin beginning the
Super Bowl you know out of your [ __ ]
mind I want to go out in public and
throw a coin in a fountain some people
see me like this
oh god it's blood pressure going through
the [ __ ] roof [ __ ] now the show in
the highlights you know you know when I
really officially thought the game was
over was when we called that [ __ ]
trick play in Atlanta it didn't even
they didn't even they covered that too
and I'm just like these guys are just
[ __ ] dialed in
anyways yeah so I did the ice house this
weekend and everything I talked about
after this is going to [ __ ] pale in
comparison the four Boston teams have
won in this century ten [ __ ] titles
do Rappaport's hilarious he [ __ ] text
me before the game he goes hey if you
guys lose today you know I'm calling you
and you better take my call and I said
oh yeah I go what if the Patriots win am
I going to hear from you and he said no
I'll be a temple hahahaha so at halftime
I got my [ __ ] head in the oven
muttering to myself just walking around
I can't I'm not watching the Lady Gaga
thing I thought she did a great job but
I got I would get nervous when
somebody's coming down on those [ __ ]
wire things that basically look like
crazy straws that you straightened out I
always feel like it at some point one of
those things is going to snap and
somebody's going to fall to their
[ __ ] death you
there's no [ __ ] gig in the world
worth doing that the people who [ __ ]
do that the level of faith that they
have there's no [ __ ] way I would do
that but anyways so I'm out there
muddling muttering in the kitchen trying
to think wow the [ __ ] I'm going to
graciously congratulate the Atlanta
phones you know any amount of [ __ ] and
I'm looking at my Twitter and all these
[ __ ] Atlanta fans well you Billy Boy
maybe a freckles you being all quiet and
I'm just muttering in the kitchen to
myself you know with Lady Gaga's on the
bad way right
I guess my kid kept me calm I just
walked in as pissed as I was I wasn't
pissed I was just [ __ ] I was I was I
almost had deflated how fun is that I
was yeah I was just [ __ ] I was
depressed I was like oh my god I mean
she that's one thing to lose but you
just get your [ __ ] ass kicked so I'm
out there and I mean what the [ __ ] I was
thinking what the [ __ ] was I even
talking about you know what is I'm
watching these goddamn highlights oh I'm
still trying to figure out how the [ __ ]
we came back all right so enough already
or not we get it your team won a [ __ ]
Super Bowl so anyways oh yeah what about
that commercial during the Super Bowl
with that new [ __ ] thing from Google
that little speaker in your house you
sitting there talking to your kid
reading it of story and it's [ __ ]
looking over your shoulder
and then you just go hey double
illinois' is a whale Megan it's like
they're wrong and then you laugh with
your daughter look at what point is a
dad run around like a Google you [ __ ]
listen to all of this you creep right
people please for the love of [ __ ]
God for the love of God do not bring
that thing into your house okay
that's the modern-day version of
bringing like a vampire or whatever I
don't even what it is you why are people
so [ __ ] stupid when it comes to their
own like privacy that thing is just on
what is it doing that's a listening
you're literally bugging your own house
uh-huh I did the Joe Rogan podcast and
he said the most depressing [ __ ] thing
he said they're making like cameras the
size of grains of sand and they're just
going to spread them around like every
[ __ ] Street so I told my block down
the street with like a leaf blower it's
just going to be everywhere everything's
going to be filmed and it's just like
that big brother [ __ ] and it's just that
book it's literally going to be wolf
you're not doing anything wrong utter
what happened bill your team won a Super
Bowl and now you're going to [ __ ]
depress everybody anyways they're the
upside here I went to UM I went to the
ice house this weekend I did two shows
and you know I special came out people
really seem to be liking it thank God
although you know I did get some [ __ ]
anytime you talk politics I got a lot of
[ __ ] from Trump fans and Hillary fans
you know they always start with the you
know that wasn't funny what happened to
you blah blah blah blah blah and I I've
been around long enough to know like
okay what was it was the was at the
Trump [ __ ] wall joke or was it the
[ __ ] Hillary's pure evil whatever the
[ __ ] I said but anyways I did two shows
working out there with Joe bartnick and
Jimmy Byrnes and I did an hour both
shows I was surprised
was really nervous because I thought
with having my daughter and everything
that like you know I hadn't been going
out to the clubs and we waited so long
for her to come and everything I was
just really nervous about where my act
was going to be so here's the deal
everybody I'm going to the comedy zone I
think it's already sold out in a
Charlotte and I'm going to be working on
I'm going to doing some clubs here over
the next month or so two months maybe
we'll figure it out once I get literally
get my act together
and I'm going to try to build up this
new hour but I was really psyched like I
know what happened I went up there and I
just was got into a good flow and a
bunch of [ __ ] that never said came out
and then there was a bunch of [ __ ] that
I kind of just left behind that kind of
came back and I never put it on a
special at least I hope I didn't I
always have a paranoia about that
because I once I do it special once I'm
done editing and I never watch it again
like why the [ __ ] would you sit there
and watch a ship or what happens is I
end up forgetting what the [ __ ] I did
from special to special so there's
always that danger I might [ __ ]
repeat something or grab a punchline
from something else
[Music]
you know God knows I've made every
[ __ ] mistake there was the makers of
comics so I was very happy about that
and I want to thank everybody ice house
to let me come out that way and I don't
know oh then we missed that [ __ ]
field goal much the highlights right now
I got to shut this off I got shut this
off this podcast is going to suck
probably very suck for people from the
way I know I had no idea [ __ ] Atlanta
Lana only won one [ __ ] title it's
entire sports existence
I thought the st. Louis Hawks I thought
they wanted title so you know what I got
to look that up because that's a great
way to get [ __ ] Laker fans [ __ ] you
know the st. Louis Hawks actually won a
[ __ ] title okay this is some Bill
Simmons [ __ ] here the saint rule I'm
gonna hit pause because I wanted to get
as [ __ ] city-level
gives a [ __ ] the st. Louis Hawks now if
they [ __ ] won a title they want a
[ __ ] title and at Lane
caught counted how to [ __ ] the Los
Angeles Laker fans count Minneapolis
Lakers titles and that other title that
they haven't that they wanted like the
NBL or some [ __ ] as an NBA title
NBA st. Louis Hawks and be a title I
want to say they won one 1958 team coach
wins st. Louis Hawks well I thought we
beat the Hawks I know the South Expedia
because that was that trivia question
last time st. Louis lost the Super Bowl
they lost to the Patriots last time they
lost the Stanley Cup final was to the
Boston Bruins last time you lost the
World Series was to the Boston Red Sox
last time they lost to the an NBA title
the st. Louis Hawks lost to the to the
Boston Celtics but it says here in 1958
they won though st. Louis Hawks they won
ok so they won in 1958 [ __ ] NBA Finals
they won alright and [ __ ] Atlanta
doesn't count that let me make sure I
say this right st. Louis wins Boston st.
Louis Boston st. Louis st. Louis yeah
they wanted six games Hawks win series
six game Atlanta doesn't count that
title
see that's why LA is gonna [ __ ] worse
with that [ __ ] you know having said that
I totally respect the lake of franchise
but nobody nobody pads their [ __ ]
stats like them because it was this game
the Celtics had I believe was Friday
night we played the Lakers and they
rebuild it and everything so it wasn't
really like a Celtic Laker thing it
always sucks from the Celtics and Lakers
play each other and we're not like you
know if one team's good the other sucks
it's there's no fun winning or losing
those games it's just like alright
whatever this team's reveal rebuilding
or we're rebuilding but so interestingly
enough at that point all time the most
regular season wins the Lakers and
Celtics were tied after all linked up 60
[ __ ] years
like 3,200 something wins a piece and
whoever won that game not that
I would go up by one you know what I
mean so basically we went to a probably
were ahead in the beginning of
Minneapolis with George Mikan and all
those guys we got ahead in the 60s and
70s was kind of a push in the 80s but in
the 90s in the in the 2000s where we
just had a rough time and they had there
was a Kobe era Kobe Shaq and all those
other [ __ ] guys they must have caught
up that can't imagine how many games
they picked up on us during those times
until you know we took a page out of
that book and bought a title in 2008 so
anyways we played each other and and I
remember they were showing the stats
that always bugs me that they say that
they have the Los Angeles Lakers have 16
titles even if you say the franchise it
just bugs the [ __ ] out of me really bill
doesn't really bug you when when your
[ __ ] team just won a Super Bowl yeah
I guess not really not really anybody
watch the [ __ ] Bruins Maple Leafs
game I have all the sports package at
this point I just sit here with my
daughter on my chest and I just sit
there and I watch the games my wife
sleeps downstairs and when she cries I
go downstairs and I just changed the
diaper and she keeps crying that means
she's hungry it's really kind of easy
the first three months and it sucks
having to get up every like hour and
eight minutes roughly at night but I
just I don't know I just go in this
[ __ ] mindset she just bumps me and
then I wake up when I just go dead I
make a little joke and I get up and my
[ __ ] achilles are so [ __ ] tight
like if something happens when you get
old and I stretch all the [ __ ] time I
stretch all the [ __ ] time and I don't
know if you guys if your old [ __ ]
maybe this is I don't this is an old guy
an old white guy an old red balls white
guy thing but I will lay on the [ __ ]
couch I swear to God I swear to God I
laid on that couch I will lay on a couch
for like [ __ ] 12 minutes and if I go
up get up to go to the [ __ ]
refrigerator it's like the first step
I've taken in eight hours I feel like
literally stop drives me up the wall I
don't know
I don't know what it is and I am [ __ ]
no matter how much down dog
stretch I do it just doesn't seem to be
working out so if you have that [ __ ]
problem here's a great stretch case of
old guy [ __ ] before I even get out of
bed now except now that I have a
daughter I just really jump up because I
don't want to do it I know if I if I
even contemplate you know laying there
I'm going to I'm going to fall back
asleep so I have to immediately jump up
but like what I used to do before being
a dad is I just what you point your toes
at your knees just do that for like 10
seconds and then point them the other
way for like 10 seconds and then do
clockwise and counterclockwise and then
you can get out of bed and for all you
young comes out there laughing at me
right now just remember this in 20 years
okay because you don't to be that guy
that blows out his [ __ ] Achilles
because you never the [ __ ] same all
right
unless you got Kobe Bryant money and you
can go to Germany right and go see
Peyton Manning's [ __ ] doctor and they
stick your [ __ ] blood in a centrifuge
whatever those [ __ ] leftover Nazis
are doing over there right they're all
running around yeah you're going to
you're going to [ __ ] pay the price so
I got to make sure I stay limba because
who knows I don't know when I haven't
really done a lot of research about kids
even though I have one I know at some
point they do start running around and
you know for the first like eight nine
years of your life being a dad as a
ground game you know you got to take it
to the mat so I going to make sure that
I stay [ __ ] limba the best I can
because I don't want to be that [ __ ]
you know I'm an old I am an old dad but
I'm a [ __ ] psycho
so that I will I will energy my way
through this you know what I mean you
know I'm going to be like Steve Brogan
my fatherhood I'm going to be like
[ __ ] Steve Grogan during the
neckbrace years and I'm just going to
tough it out you know when you just
stand there and this is backward you're
going to hit a quarterback and you would
just see this [ __ ] guy
running full-speed and he would stand
there until the last second and then he
let it fly to Stanley Morgan and right
as they started to follow the ball you
just see the beginning of the impact and
Steve Grogan or the other guy would go
flying out of the right side of your
screen as they follow the ball to the
left that's going to be me is a [ __ ]
quarterback
I mean as a dead so anyway so at the
road I go to you know I'm going to
Charlotte going to go to the comedy zone
and doing a couple of shows out there if
I get there early a night enough I'm
going to go to the shallot Hornets game
and and in I'm closing in by the way and
I'm going to do Carolina and you know
and I'm not smoking cigars because I got
this [ __ ] life insurance saying I got
to tell you I'm smoking cigar like well
over two months and I feel [ __ ] so
good about you know so I don't know I
might just keep going who knows I can't
be that smelly dad killing and smelling
like like I went to the track Oh big
[ __ ] thing in my life my wife might
let me bring the [ __ ] in the game
changer you know the flat top grill we
got it [ __ ] downstairs in my backyard
right and so the kitchens [ __ ]
upstairs does lado this house is
completely [ __ ] up right so I going to
run up and down the [ __ ] stairs you
know it's a pain in the ass I finally
because I got I got rid of a ton of [ __ ]
I put my my old Ludwig kit up for sale
the symbols everything it's the whole
[ __ ] John Bonham setup 1971 green
Sparkle Ludwig all the Paiste cymbals
even the Rogers hi-hat that he had I'm
finally letting go of that that fanboy
era is done you know I had a lot of fun
with that kid but it's just [ __ ]
gigantic and 26 inch bass drum I don't
want that you know I want I want to I
want to 12 14 16 22 kick that's what the
[ __ ] I want
I never liked the sound of those
I like the hi-hats but I never liked the
sound of his the [ __ ] ride he could
make it sound good I couldn't so I've
been getting into a bunch of other
different sounds all this [ __ ] that I
was heard in my [ __ ] head I really
just kind of came to this realization as
someone who does that as a hobby that I
don't know that I was you're not really
creating you're just sort of recreating
when you do [ __ ] like that like you get
so into a musician that you want to buy
all the [ __ ] the exact [ __ ] that they
had and then what it's [ __ ] it's just
you know there was just I just kept
picturing John Bonham coming back to
life and for whatever reason walking
into my house and I go oh my god John
Bonham hey you like Jesus but you're a
drummer
come on it hey by the way you know I'm a
huge fan of yours yeah come on check out
my drum kit and he would walk in and see
his exact drum kit right down to the
Rogers hi-hat and then he would get like
that [ __ ] I was joking with a buddy
of mine today or what text he would get
that single white female vibe for me and
he would just slowly back out of the
room like oh yeah that's great
just [ __ ] leave so I don't know I'm
going to go out I'm trying out all the
kits I heard that Gretsch broadcaster
with the three-ply is [ __ ] you know
has a great sound
DW obviously majoring drums
I grew up everybody that I watched used
to play the tamarins of Tama how are the
[ __ ] Fayette pearl the Ludwig's you
it's funny I Phil Rudd always played
sonar or whatever and the great Benny
Greg plays those but they don't [ __ ]
nobody has them they're like these
amazing [ __ ] drums is super expensive
and I've never seen I've never seen a
mom you know not that I go to Guitar
Center anymore you know I go there's a
place out here called professional drum
shop and they got some great [ __ ] up
there plus a smoke you know they're like
a legendary place you know dude I went
in there I know this is all drum [ __ ]
but i ran to a drummer recently go talk
more drums man sigh [ __ ] it i talked
enough sports here right oh I didn't
talk about you see McQuaid's fight he
fought this guy I think guys last name
Smith oh my god they had a great fight
it was an old-school
haymaker thing and makuey got the best
of him in the end just too [ __ ] tough
guys but uh McQuaid got the last shot in
and the guy kind of went down but I mean
the guy took a bunch of shots but of
course Maple Leaf fans were like oh but
quays wearing a shield what a [ __ ]
sick you think a lot of people say no
matter what no matter how about
convincing your guy wins the fight
there's always a [ __ ] excuse but then
my wife goes yeah because I was reading
the comments it goes it's [ __ ] unreal
because I'm sitting there going like
well why didn't it just punch McQuaid's
[ __ ] helmet off the way McQuaid did
to him there was always that option
right but when I brought it up at the
lis fans were bitching that McQuaid had
on advisor my wife goes yeah I was going
to ask you about that I was just like
all right he's got on half a welder's
mask maybe you know throwing up a pot
every by you know over and under most
shots go to the side of the helmet
anyways right I'm old enough to remember
when guys who didn't wear helmets fought
guys who had helmets and then that was
the [ __ ] move and now I guess the [ __ ]
move is you know you can keep your
[ __ ] helmet on if somebody else is
cutting up the [ __ ] hand punching the
plastic but if you have a visor then
you're a [ __ ] I don't get it all I know
it's McQuaid's one of the best fighters
one of the toughest guys in the league
and it was a great [ __ ] fight and
that game even though we lost was
unbelievable was it six to five or
something like that five to four I can't
even remember everyone's at least always
have great games really have great games
in you know even though we live we lost
the last two we won three in a row but
the Bruins are playing way better way
better and they're playing like the
Bruins again you know I think we're
actually up to like the seventh seed so
all the [ __ ] bellyache and that I'm
doing I should have just kept my [ __ ]
mouth shut because what else you know
now people write articles are they
taking too early so anyways the drum
soft getting back to the drum [ __ ]
yeah ran into somebody saying oh you
should [ __ ]
talk more about that drum stuff so
that's basically what I want to do is I
want to get like just I can't even like
trying to explain the sound to a buddy
mine that I'm looking for with cymbals
but I'm going to try all of them out
savings my no I love the sound of those
things at least you know it's weird as
you see the professional guys playing
and they make them sound so [ __ ] good
and then you buy the exact one and then
you like it doesn't sound the way it
started what he did it that's because
you're a comedian so yes I'm going to
sell that kit and then the money I get
from that I'm going to the game plan is
to buy that a new kit brand [ __ ] new
no more of this [ __ ] old [ __ ] trying
to figure stuff out although I was going
to say about that pro drum shop place
this is how [ __ ] great that places I
had a snare stand and one of the thing
you screw into the hold it into place
whatever the [ __ ] you call it would you
call that a nut I have no idea all I
know is it got stripped and it didn't it
didn't work anymore now if you ever went
to Guitar Center they'd be like well you
know you got to buy a new one I walked
into there and a guy just takes it and
he went in the back he [ __ ] machine
to think so it worked again because
there you go I was like how much he's
like hang on three bucks four bucks that
doesn't exist anymore you know what that
still exists straight across the board
in one industry is when you go to a
cobbler you go into a [ __ ] shoe store
those guys they don't give a [ __ ]
they're in there with all those
chemicals they don't know what [ __ ]
year it is you ever try to go into one
to a shoe store where they whether they
actually repair shoes a cobbler I guess
seems weird to use that word but I think
that's what it is right the modern-day
blacksmith a cobbler and you go in then
you can't even [ __ ] breathe you got
to do that thing when you trying to
pinch your nostrils together as you talk
to him yet can you lucky fix his belt
can you out put some more soles on these
the guy's a guy never used to think
they'd never take like it's always like
cash they're like right now to receipt
you can't read any of their [ __ ]
writing
I don't know this one of those you know
something that's like a great place so
like one of those [ __ ] Harry Potter
type of movies to start like a new
franchise something about when you go to
cobblers like stepping back into time
and they be seeing there'd be some old
weird guy maybe played by Billy Crystal
they put some prosthetics on his nose or
some [ __ ]
then he do that one time with that guy
that guy from the Washington Bullets
mirror son did they do a movie together
I don't what the [ __ ] it wasn't one of
those Ebenezer Scrooge [ __ ] movies
but anyways you think you going to the
cobbler there's some sort of backroom
area I loved pitching out ideas for
movies because I'm never going to I'm
not going to [ __ ] write one not going
through that [ __ ] axe grinder that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I why would you do that to
yourself
you don't I mean if you can travel the
country telling [ __ ] and dick jokes why
you on [ __ ] earth would you walk into
that [ __ ] heart breaking of a [ __ ]
arena so I'm just any movie idea I have
I'm just throwing out there and I know
so many [ __ ] rights it makes it I
hope you make a [ __ ] billion dollars
I don't give a [ __ ] you know why cuz the
pain is Tom Brady is the greatest
quarterback of all time you can say
about five [ __ ] rings Oh God Jesus
Christ you know sad you know he's
[ __ ] sad people there are right now
and I don't just mean in Atlanta I just
mean Patriot haters in general because
the Patriots have been so [ __ ]
successful and they've been so [ __ ]
vilified you know for the [ __ ] that they
do that everybody else [ __ ] does
right but [ __ ] that literally
watching them lose gives other people
hope you know gives you hope that you
can call up your cable company dispute
the bill and get some money off of it
right gives you hope that you can [ __ ]
in there you know elect a politician and
they they going to [ __ ] not sell out
to the corporation's you don't mean that
that's what the Patriots are because
that's their level of [ __ ] success
there's going to be a lot of slumped
shoulders
going to work tomorrow or maybe right
now maybe you're one of those people
maybe you're driving in your car right
now and your shoulders are so slumped
you're not even using your hands to
[ __ ] steer you just got your
shoulders [ __ ] wrapped around it just
all [ __ ] caved in as the thrill ride
says right maybe one of those people
well you know what I say [ __ ] it grow up
all right just a goddamn game I would
have taken the loss
I was already ready already always
sitting there right my [ __ ]
concession speech you know
un-fuckin'-believable anyways alright
let's get out of his [ __ ] vortex here
I know if I got the advertising yet for
this week
oh yes of the game plans I'm going to
buy that [ __ ] kit and then I'm going
to find some rehearsal space somewhere
nearby some [ __ ] place for a couple
hundred bucks a month and I'm going to
[ __ ] put it in there all right and
whenever I can that's going to be my
[ __ ] mancave
alright because you know what the [ __ ]
happens you know I mean you have a kid
you married you know gradually all he is
[ __ ] just starts [ __ ] disappeared
okay
my wife can't [ __ ] wait she couldn't
[ __ ] you know she's happy I like the
drums but no [ __ ] woman wants a
[ __ ] 26 inch bass drum being a
[ __ ] travel case like I'm on the
[ __ ] road with the Rolling Stones and
another [ __ ] floor drum stacked up on
top of that you know in front of the bed
in the guest room nobody [ __ ] wants
it well they don't want it so I don't
but you know I got to give this to her
she never told me to sell the [ __ ]
thing all I know is when I told her that
I was selling it
I saw the excitement in her eye and then
I tested or not saying yeah but then I'm
going to go buy another one and it's
going to live right there and she just
stared at me and I just started laughing
I'm trying not to be a dick though now
that you know our dynamic has changed
you know like I'm going to put my truck
and [ __ ] storage and I'll Drive it on
the weekends I knows a lot of married
guys why not go now you're never going
to drive it and then you get a [ __ ]
sell it
I actually thought about selling it to
you know just this whole [ __ ] stream
Lyman mine in my life get my [ __ ]
[ __ ] down but I can't [ __ ] do it i
just and i drive that truck this stupid
smile on my [ __ ] face it's just I
can't do it
can't [ __ ] do it so I'm just going to
put in storage and I'll heat that
[ __ ] money I hate being the storage
guy I got stuff in storage yeah and
people have stuff in storage are just
too lazy to have a [ __ ] yard sale you
know I mean just [ __ ] sell it sell it
how long has it been there what it you
know it's funny just hanging on to those
[ __ ] memories I'm telling you dude
it's a [ __ ] disease and I got it I
got it bad I'm a sentimental fool I got
it I got to get rid of all of that [ __ ]
I never look at it it just becomes
another box in the [ __ ] attic you
know then you [ __ ] die someday and
then somebody's looking through it and
there's all this weird [ __ ] in there
that you kept some menu from [ __ ]
Tulsa Oklahoma for whatever what the
[ __ ] is and then you know he just given
these people this big job that they got
to go and slow this [ __ ] up
oh is this owner [ __ ] just a website
I'll let them in nom de nom show where
all the shredders go see here you know
is it not Sam ash the other day right
and I want to see if they haven't what
the [ __ ] do I know I went there I
actually can't say why I went there I
won't get caught I just had all these
extra drumsticks and I had all this [ __ ]
that I was getting rid of that I just
don't [ __ ] use and I'm like when I do
it this stuff I can't sell old
drumsticks on a [ __ ] on eBay or some
[ __ ] so what I did was I just bundled
them all together
and just left them in their parking lot
you know some kids gonna walk in there
and be like holy [ __ ] I guess see if I
like 40 pairs of [ __ ] all these
different drumsticks over the years I
just bundled them all and just stuck in
there a [ __ ] cowbell a couple of
so at that point I'm like I get kind of
feeling guilty so I went in to say I'm
ashes I gotta buy a [ __ ] pair of
drumsticks and it was some kid in there
just doing that [ __ ] drumming where
he's amazing but all the whole [ __ ]
thing it's just one phil after another
those [ __ ] linear thirty-second note
[ __ ] fills played nine million miles
an hour
every [ __ ] after what just all sounds
the same but don't act too guilty we got
a delivery I'm so [ __ ] like I almost
started laughing because the kid was
amazing but after a while it's just like
dude you sound like you're [ __ ]
selling keep [ __ ] snorted a couple of
eight-balls
Jesus Christ maybe I'm just getting old
I'm gonna put a little air in there you
know the old guy who can't play as good
as a young kid he's jealous of his chops
but Jesus Christ all right what am I
doing here I'm trying to find the
[ __ ] numb there we go
the live reeds oh [ __ ] here we go
sherry berry there's no one like your
Valentine this year treat them to an
unforgettable gift that's as unique as
they are two chocolate covered
strawberries it's pretty pedestrian
isn't it
yeah you're really [ __ ] unique kid
some is a [ __ ] is a matzah cracker
with a little butter on it well [ __ ] it
was delicious
the timeless classic what you're saying
is there a timeless classic when I think
in a way or maybe you're saying they're
old
there's an old people gift all right I
get from Sherry's Barry shows shows her
you put thought into finding the perfect
gift
well I can't why can't the women bye
guys chocolate-covered strawberries is
this does this read sexist all right
here we go
freshly dipped strawberries from
sharri's berries starting at just $19.99
plus shipping or double the berries for
just $10 more just go to berries calm
BERR IES calm and use my code Burke
help support our show by supporting our
sponsors use my code bar surprise are at
the office slash works workplace put
against throw matter her co-workers are
sure to be just a little jealous yeah
just a little Oh chocolate strawberries
oh Jesus
somebody got a hand job last night and
she'll be overjoyed
I'm joking these things are [ __ ]
delicious alright choose a gift from
Sherry's berries incredible collection
of gifts your gift will be perfectly
packaged in a gift box with all the
details taken care of Sherry's berries
will deliver your gift fresh and on time
guaranteed or your money back with
Valentine's Day right around the corner
there's only one way to get Sherry's
berry starting at $19.99
why don't they why do they write all
that [ __ ] who's [ __ ] kidding hope
you're right guy you got to get at
something you don't want to [ __ ] do
it just get it just get her this or get
her something else and get her this pad
the [ __ ] thing like the Lakers with
their championships add this one this is
your NBL [ __ ] title you're throwing
20 bucks chocolate-covered strawberries
you know what I mean
so you got the gift and then you give it
some [ __ ] you know it's got sugar in it
it'll make her [ __ ] it'll give her a
little rush right to joke just visit
berries calm BER our IES calm click on
the microphone in the top right hand
corner and type in ber that's berries
calm and use my code Brewer help support
our show by supporting our sponsors use
my code oh the classics the classics
here on out both vote me undies me
undies the greatest of all [ __ ] time
but it'll be undies me undies all you
[ __ ] have to whine when you say Brady's
the best he probably got velvet balls
too so he doesn't need me undies who
gives a [ __ ] he's got a ring for every
finger on his right hand
alright this Valentine's Day give a gift
that they can unwrap again and again
matching underwear from me undies
Valentine's Day is near and it's a go
ants go time for a thoughtful gift
hunting the undies has you covered with
limited edition matching pairs of undies
for you and yours this is such an odd
gift this is like
almost like a sex swing or something his
Valentine's Day got you stumped forget
the cliches and give the gift that looks
great it feels great and will make
everyone happy me undies fancy dinners
in chocolate last a night shot fire
flowers last a week
in common this year give the gift of
looking great and feeling great every
day with the world's most comfortable
underwear heads up valentine's day is
February 14th February 6 guys she got
[ __ ] I always got to say guys right
because women you don't the [ __ ] do
anything what are you gonna do huh so I
can push your tits together and throw a
little perfume down the middle what else
do you got to do put on song alright
Valentine's Days rides fortune
don't panic get your heart get your
heart on and show some love with me
undies matching undies please include
all of the following points during your
read all right of course I will the
undies are the perfect gift for you and
your Valentine this holiday they're
unbelievably soft and come in limited
edition prints we we got all this I'm
not reading oh [ __ ] okay this is the
okay they got [ __ ] underwear it
matches its it's cute you know number
back in the day when people had a de
[ __ ] answering machine and they would
do it together like Hello this is the
Johnson and together we're happy another
day like [ __ ] worship this is the
underwear version of that
alright the undies has special limited
edition Valentine's undies which means
you and your Valentine's can match and
yeah it's as cute as it sounds slash
creepy and if for some reason you and me
undies aren't a perfect match they'll
give you your money back and let you
keep the first pair there's no refund on
a bad fancy dinner all right they offer
free shipping and for a limited time
listeners to the station get 20% off the
first order but you have to go to the
undies calm slash / with the undies Emme
UND i es better day guarantee you have
nothing to lose so don't wait any longer
go to the undies dot-com slash bro right
now for 20% off your first order that's
me undies calm slash / alright when we
got left two more two more hanging to
hang in there Pro flowers are you tired
of guessing what she wants a Valentine's
Day maybe you're a little sick of her
what are you doing in that relationship
huh [ __ ] would you waste
time getting flowers but maybe is still
lover when you love an easy fail-proof
way to look like a pro this year Pro
flowers is making it easier than ever by
taking all the guesswork out on top of
their already low prices right now you
can get two dozen assorted roses with a
free glass case for $29.99 plus shipping
and handling or upgrade and for 9.99
more you can get two dozen long-stem
assorted roses with premium vase and
chocolate just go to proflowers.com use
my or upgrade even more and have a
gigolo delivered then just [ __ ] your
wife while you watch the replay the
Patriots game come on man you can bang
your wife whenever you want to what are
you going to watch a man when his fifth
[ __ ] Super Bowl ring as a quarterback
I'm sorry
should I said that just go to
proflowers.com use my code bar help
support by supporting our sponsors use
my code burp you are our pick your
flowers and then check out in two
minutes I've done this before I did it
for my mother I did our Mother's Day was
easy as hell you just go there bing bang
boom zippity-doo-dah nothing oh my god
is shortened and you never left your
desk you can literally put down your
gameboy knock this out [ __ ] two
minutes then go right back to talking
[ __ ] online alright you can't beat the
pricing convenience ProFlowers takes
care of the details you can just sit
back and look awesome when I send
flowers
I trust blowpro flowers to get it right
is the only yeah that's my quarterback
my quarterback throw flowers here's the
only way to get two dozen assorted roses
with free glass vase starting at $29.99
just go to proflowers.com and use my
code bar help support support our show
by supporting our sponsors use my code
bar that's proflowers.com click on the
microphone and type in my code bar don't
wait order today this deal expires soon
and finally lastly but not leastly
Dollar Shave Club everybody Dollar Shave
Club always gives you a close smooth
shave and you can't beat the convenience
or the price you don't have to choose
between settling for cheap bag and
disposables or praying out the nose for
a razor with a laser pointer
17 blades it's awful then Dollar Shave
Club broke on to the scene with the
smarter choice before Dollar Shave Club
there was no middle ground there was the
haves and have-nots it was easy to save
money and get a painful shave from a
disposable like the ones that you get
for free a gym which felt like shaving
with a piece of glass or pay a fortune
for the latest shave breakthrough in
quotes
you didn't need like a laser chin
detector or 17 more blades it was
[ __ ] stupid Dollar Shave Club is the
best of both worlds you get a premium
shave quality a disposable shaved prices
if you haven't tried Dollar Shave Club
jet you're missing out I don't know what
the [ __ ] you waiting for it's an amazing
shave and an affordable price don't you
sit there with a dumb look on your face
go to dollarshaveclub.com slash /
there's no smarter choices on the market
and right now
they're giving away a one-month trial of
any of their razors for only $1 with
free shipping and after that it's just a
few bucks a month there's no long term
commitments no hidden fees and you can
cancel whenever you want
get your $1 trial at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / / all
right there you go ok that's done let's
uh let's all go to the lobby buff up out
of that boo-boo all right let's um let's
read some of these [ __ ] things
hey did I call it a what I said it was
going to be a classic although I don't
know if I can a classic for one side I
thought it would be a classic for both
for both sides but um alright enough
okay the [ __ ] as Lana fans have
suffered enough okay let's just [ __ ]
get through this okay alright first
football game watched from Sweden bill
birdy being from speed saying that
football isn't big here is an
understatement I don't how to talk of it
but is actually a Swedish accent isn't
it I have no idea but I've been
listening to your podcast for a couple
years now
and you're rambling over NFL have made
me interested I'll look at that maybe
you just got me a job at the NFL you
know maybe I could be on when you're
little Google things in your room and
you [ __ ] talking in whatever the hell
you guys
over there righteous magic - that's what
it sounds like to me I can't imagine
what I sound like you probably a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
alright I finally sat down and watched a
game and it was the Super Bowl that just
ended and what a game I'm sold
Jesus Christ when the [ __ ] of this guy
send us in I love hockey mostly but I
found a new game to love Tom Brady best
QB ever says the Swedish commentators I
have no clue but I believe them I guess
thanks for getting me into the game
better late than never I love people who
can speak a second language that's
[ __ ] amazing sorry for the bad
English grammar - he did the [ __ ]
Boston accent perfectly in a 2nd
language he says it's early and I'm
tired all the best to you Nia and the
newborn baby girl loved the special and
looking forward to season 2 his efforts
of family no it's funny I was just
thinking I got to get over there I
missed you guys on the last tour I
didn't do the Norway the Oslo Stockholm
Helsinki one I got to make sure I do
that at some point but anyone Jesus
Christ dude I don't want to rain on your
parade but you just win most football
games are not that exciting you know
boring the first half was well I guess
for me it was depressing I guess it was
exciting for Atlanta fans oh god I can't
you know I had a buddy of mine actually
originally passed away which sucks but
he told me this [ __ ] story when the
Red Sox had like two outs in 1986
against the Mets he had the wire office
champagne bottle and he had to put it
back on after they lost hey maybe this
will be for Atlanta fans this will be
cathartic for you if you want to share
your I thought we were going to win
stories and then I had to put the
[ __ ] wire back on the champagne
bottle I'll read them next week or
anybody out there if you have those
we're going to [ __ ] win and then you
lose the [ __ ] game I got a bunch of
them I can share with you I got a bunch
of those I get a bunch of those
those could be [ __ ] really close and
[ __ ] always hilarious it's that's
comedy man if it works out there's no
comedy it's like when when you fight
like if the Patriots [ __ ] got their
asses kicked out of it that would have I
already knew I was gonna just got our
asses ripped away the whole [ __ ]
thing worked out stead I came on gushing
here like I just won the [ __ ]
Publishers Clearing House I cannot
[ __ ] believe they came back and won
that game that is why I get [ __ ]
stunned cannot [ __ ] believe it
all right British dentistry hey Bill I
remember hearing that you used to be a
dentist before you stand up career took
a slanted dental question here I was not
a dentist but I love that you put that
out there and then I'll probably end up
on my Wikipedia page I don't know why we
British don't take dental care seriously
I have pretty decent teeth for a British
person probably in the top 15% of people
British people that is I always brush
twice a day unless I get drunk and
forget sometimes after going out
drinking but I noticed that when I was
in America my teeth were [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are you lot over there in the land
of McDonald's and Coca Cola doing to
keep your teeth so clean is there
toothpaste in the water supply
well there was fluoride sometimes they
put in too much and people got those
white spots in their teeth seriously do
you do you lot live at the dentist a lot
meaning all you guys even the working
class over in America seemed to have
good teeth yeah we do well I mean braces
are a big thing over here I don't know
if you guys have those over there yet
those are a big thing people also can
get like their teeth bleached caps are a
lot better than they used to be yeah but
at the end of the day dude you got to
brush your teeth after you eat and
there's certain things like drinking
coffee I guess your tea over there would
probably stain the [ __ ] out of them I'd
say one that's [ __ ] brutal red wine
red
and why makes your teeth gray yeah just
brush and floss you know I got this life
insurance test coming up because I'm
getting my affairs in order
not I got a kid they told me they said
have you been to the dentist and I said
yes and I said was any gum disease and I
said no and they said that's good
I said I go they're worried about my
teeth fall out and they said no gum
disease can be a sign of something wrong
with your heart it's like what I never
heard that
never heard that I know if you had
[ __ ] up teeth that usually and led to
you not chewing your food as well which
led to stomach problems and then
problems with your intestine and then
down to your ash it's all [ __ ]
connected but I had never heard of that
so anyways you said to put in
perspective how bad some British people
are with dental hygiene I know someone
who would only brush their teeth once or
twice a week I had to buy them an
electric toothbrush as a not-so-subtle
hint that not brushing your teeth is
[ __ ] disgusting
I guess there's a lot of truth to
stereotypes PSL be amazed that you
actually manage to read this without
stuttering you illiterate [ __ ] ah you
know something if that whole [ __ ]
thing was just to get that joke and that
was an absolute masterpiece you know if
you actually just picked that subject
British dentistry just to fool us so we
would actually read it and was all
self-deprecating just the end just to
call me a [ __ ] illiterate [ __ ] the
stuttering illiterate [ __ ] is great that
was tremendous
I don't even know if you serious anymore
but yeah that's listen I when I worked
in a dental office all I did was just
hand the [ __ ] I was an assistant I was
certified to take x-rays I wasn't a
hygienist I wasn't any of that other
[ __ ] so anyways yeah it was one of my
first jokes this guy came in and guy was
like you know I understand wasn't
following my teeth me and I brushed my
teeth almost every day and my joke was
oh really do you wipe your ass almost
time you take a [ __ ] I mean come on
people is this thing on
when I first jokes everybody that was
there you know what they call throwback
Thursday
now I'm actress paying alimony if you
just brush your [ __ ] teeth I think
you'll be fine you know and especially
before you go to bed to just like go out
drinking and doing on [ __ ] and then just
go to bed and just let that [ __ ] just
get in a it's gross it's [ __ ] gross
should brush floss and you should use
mouthwash you know and then you should
find a [ __ ] woman that does the same
thing and that's the person you should
be kissing over there everybody else
I don't know Jesus Christ oh my god it's
[ __ ] gross anyways actress paying
alimony bill wondering if you saw this a
fairly famous actress has been paying or
unemployed husband alimony and she's
complaining that he hasn't tried to get
a job she's paying him 20 grand a month
does that make him a bum is this like a
trick question if I had a son that ever
[ __ ] did that I would disown him it's
[ __ ] unbelievable I've seen that you
know that that does happen when one of
the alright here we go let's let me read
this thing here according to a court
document so-and-so is paid over a half a
million dollars to her former spouse
since 2015 these funds include around
150,000 and such as such residuals I'm
not going to say who the [ __ ] this as I
put people's dirty laundry out they even
though it's already out here she gave
birth to that daughter in March of last
year this person alleges that the other
guy cheated on him with the credit oh
he's saying that she cheated on him with
her co-star a point of contention in the
divorce the divorce has since been
finalized the terms of support have not
hence a temporary agreement where she
has to pay this dude over 20 grand
monthly well you know if they do get
divorced if she's out here in California
she's going to get [ __ ]
going to documents so-and-so is
requested to be able to stop sending the
guy those payments saying that the guy
has made no effort to get a job of his
own and is living off of her
yeah man I mean that's when you just
start thinking murderous thoughts you
know I think that's you know it's bad
enough when a [ __ ] woman does it I
mean I'm really doing like a double
standard here but yeah dude I mean
you're not a [ __ ] man if you do
something like that and if you're a
woman and you don't try to get a job
you're a piece of [ __ ] but you know what
I know you don't give a [ __ ] so you know
women don't give a [ __ ] we actually get
off of the fact that you [ __ ] you
know am I really going to turn this
around to slamming women I'm really
going to figure out how to do that when
there's a woman a woman's a victim in
this bill okay
yeah that's complete [ __ ] it's
complete [ __ ] I straight across the
board think that's [ __ ] up all right
now okay she's a [ __ ] drug addict and
he has to stay at home the entire time
to watch their kid I mean they just had
that kid that is actually his job that I
understand you know what I mean God
there for the grace of God July holy
[ __ ] I just don't understand how it gets
to that you know what I mean
I didn't get to that point where you
with somebody you have a [ __ ] kid -
I'm probably jinxing myself you have a
kid together and then it's like you
decided to make another person together
and within a [ __ ] two years of that
you're getting to like Jesus Christ the
one thing they had a one-night stand but
they've already married it it's [ __ ]
nuts all right who knows maybe the guy
went nuts maybe she did [ __ ] around him
I don't know
all right coaching daughter's sports
teams coaching Dillo supposed to be '
they're coaching daughters sports team
all right congrats on not pulling out ha
ha no thank you
I was wondering if you will coach any of
your daughter's sports teams when she
gets older what sports would you like to
see her grow up to play
jalisa to you and Nia and thank you for
another great special oh you're welcome
I'm glad you enjoyed it
um what I do that uh I don't know I I
don't want to insert myself into my
daughter's life like that I'd like her
to have to learn how to deal with
another adult especially if she doesn't
like him and learn how to [ __ ] you
know deal with a coach that's a little
hard nosed or whatever you know I mean
I'm not going to be one of those people
that you know pretty much [ __ ] kid if
my kid stinks I'm not going to [ __ ]
make them play my kid right I'm not
going to be I just all of that [ __ ] I
don't understand any of that and if your
coach is [ __ ] hard-nosed and you kid
comes home crying about it it's a little
tough in the [ __ ] up learn how to deal
you think this is the first [ __ ]
you're ever going to [ __ ] run into in
life but it's not you know you know what
work twice as hard make that [ __ ] guy
regret that he ever yelled at you well
that woman that's what you do you just
you just go [ __ ] harder that's what
you do what you don't do is [ __ ] mope
around about it and try less alright if
your motivation even if your motivation
is [ __ ] this guy you know you're going
to play better but you got to use that
negative [ __ ] and turn it into a
positive and I'm a big believer in
playing organized sports and organized
sports has gotten a brutal reputation
over the years some of it is justified a
lot of it wasn't a lot of it was a bunch
of uncoordinated people who did not have
a good [ __ ] experience and then
married someone else who was also
uncoordinated and then watched their
toddler growing up bumping into [ __ ] and
was like oh my god
they're going to suck at sports too and
they're going to have the same pain that
I did or I had right and then rather
than scaring them away from sports and
going hey maybe you're a writer or maybe
you're into son
is these [ __ ] uncoordinated [ __ ] had
to stick them in sports and then they
had to dumb the whole thing down where
everybody gets a ribbon I had a buddy of
mine recently said or is there somebody
doing a joke I can't say it if it was a
joke
who the [ __ ] told me this sort was no
somebody's bit I can't do it ah [ __ ] it
had to do basically with playing little
kids playing softball and when they
first played they played without the
ball and they pretended that they hit
the [ __ ] thing so nobody would have
the pressure of making an error and they
could be like nice catch way to go and
all of that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] insane no
I'm not going to do that and
unfortunately my wife is on the same
page and I told you that somebody sent
us some Boston you know sports shirts
and they were they would appear with the
logos of the teams and they were in pink
and my wife was just going like yes
she's not wearing those don't like what
cuz you hate sports but she goes no
because they're pink she goes if she's
gonna wear the team stuff she's wearing
the team colors I think I already told
you this guys it was like you have any
[ __ ] idea how much real sports fans
would appreciate what you just said you
don't even like sports you have no
[ __ ] idea you just you just like you
stepped in [ __ ] there that's like the
that's exactly it anyway I don't know
[ __ ] I guess so well I coach no I
wouldn't do that you know if I was ever
to coach I would be I think I would be
an assistant coach I'd be the rah-rah
guy if they were little and ship it's
like I couldn't [ __ ] sit there
yelling at kids and also I don't think I
know enough about the [ __ ] game I've
watched a bunch of sports but to
actually coach a team and teach somebody
how to get better I mean I think I'd be
I'll be a good dad if she wants to be go
in the backyard or not I hit a ball or
shoot some baskets I think I'm good at
that but like you know that's a hell of
a responsibility and I have a very
volatile personality and I just I don't
want
the Earl Weaver [ __ ] eight-year-olds
up this scream and yell and bull sing
what's the other meditating and possibly
going to therapy works out but I'm more
excited just to see what she gravitates
to I'm going exposure to as much music
and different [ __ ] as I possibly can and
then just sort of stand back see what
she goes after and then just encourage
her and if it's like a Fae if it's a
phase it's a face and then she moves on
to something else but my parents were
really cool about kind of letting us do
you know whatever the [ __ ] we wanted to
do as far as trying [ __ ] in life like my
parents who never gave me [ __ ] about
being a stand-up comedian and that's
pretty when I you know the amount of
comics that I've run into where to this
day like they're super successful and
their parents still going respect what
they do thinking that they're just up
there [ __ ] around it's pretty amazing
so I got really lucky in that department
so that's one of the good things I'm
keeping from my my upbringing so long
story short now but I will go to every
[ __ ] game I'll go to every game and
I'm not going to argue with other
parents and if the [ __ ] referee
stinks and it's screwing my team I'm
just going to sit there and just you
know I'm just not going to be that
[ __ ] guy I'm going to make jokes we
won't be laughing but uh you know what
the big thing is is when I go to her
games I'm going to be sober so that's
going to really tone down it's when I go
to games that I've had a few I can't
resist there's a crowd there's jokes to
be made even way back in the day when I
was [ __ ] you know way more
introverted I had a couple of beers and
I would be in Sullivan Stadium and I
would yell out [ __ ] and people in my
section would laugh and I would just
build my confidence and suck some games
I would yell out the first thing that
would bomb and then I wouldn't say
anything again until the third quarter
and then I'd throw it out but only have
like you know 50% confidence so it only
did okay and it'd be like my literally
my bad set
back then like bombing was I went to a
game and I yelled up some [ __ ] and
nobody laughed but I don't know it's not
the way it used to be because
everybody's so concerned about kids and
political correctness and [ __ ] public
drunkenness and [ __ ] but back in the day
like what was going on in the field was
was about half as entertaining as what
was going on in the stands it was just
and it was all just sophomoric stupid I
remember sitting we had like and not
endzone seats we were sitting right at
the corner you know like past the goal
line we basically sitting like facing
the endzone and then there was the
endzone seats and they have this beer
commercial
light beer from Miller and they said the
big fights last feeling tastes great
less filling tastes like they were
having a fight you know over over if it
didn't fill you up as much or if it
tasted better so that became like this
stupid thing that people did you'd be a
someone figured out one time stood up
and yelled at the other section said
less filling that someone else stood up
and screamed tastes great and they would
all be yelling like yeah we're doing the
commercial this is before YouTube so
this is actually fun so to be one
sessional that felt like no go thanks
Brian
last time thanks great and of course
because it was a bunch of drunks drunk
males it immediately went sophomoric and
it eventually became [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] and we would do that
20 times a game and it would be just as
funny the 20th time as it was the first
time because we were all a bunch of
immature [ __ ] idiots I miss those
days you know I really [ __ ] missed
ugh that was a lot of fun back then now
it's just so you know the balls in play
don't go to you see there's some [ __ ]
old lady with a construction hat on
telling you to stop I don't know ah just
a [ __ ] curmudgeon what are you going
to do but anyways that's the podcast for
this week thank you guys so much for
listening and thank you everybody who's
been watching my special and giving me
the great reviews I was really proud of
this special and they
a chance to watch it please check it out
obviously that helps me out with my
relationship with Netflix and my ability
to do eventually do another one and if
you've already seen it and you enjoyed
it please tell somebody else to check it
out and that's it and congratulations to
the New England Patriots holy [ __ ]
championship number five
unbelievable unbelievable once again I'm
not [ __ ] around here my condolences
to Atlanta fans I have been there it
[ __ ] sucks but you guys got a hell of
a team and I hope you back there next
year and you get you get your [ __ ]
win alright that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on you check in on you on
Thursday and all you comes in Charlotte
I'll see you on Wednesday
I